jean-pierre ternes amian médecin
radiologue président du rps de président
au pardon da de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé libéraux de la
région auvergne rhône-alpes
pierre-jean un terme interne amian
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors face à la
progression exponentielle de l'épidémie
vous proposé l'élargissement immédiat
des horaires du couvre-feu à partir de
19 heures on le disait l'instauration
d'un confinement les samedis et
dimanches
ce soir est ce que vous avez le
sentiment que votre proposition est
entendu par l'exécutif ou qu'elles
pourraient être entendus disons que
j'espère qu'elle sera entendue par
l'exécutif on a une accélération du
temps politique puisqu'ils un conseil de
défense demain je n'ai aucune nouvelle
j'ai informé tout à fait loyalement le
directeur de l' agence que jal de santé
dès vendredi qu'on allait publier ce
communiqué parce que ça me semble est
vital que l'on prenne position nous
médecins libéraux de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes
il a fait remonter à priori
l'information à monsieur seulement sur
salomon de la direction générale de la
santé
après j'ai pas de contacts
gouvernementaux
par contre clairement l'appel qu'on a
lancée et virales puisque je suis
officiellement en vacances
la première fois depuis on va dire
janvier et je peux vous dire que c'est
viral ensuite vedette à plus d'une
dizaine de télévisions une quinzaine de
radios en moins de 48 heures donc je
pense qu'on a réellement été
interpellées on va dire la presse et par
ricochet l'opinion française parce que
cette épidémie devient très très
préoccupante très préoccupante parce que
très concrètement vous qu'est ce que
vous observez au quotidien alors très
concrètement en l'espace de 10 jours
lundi dernier on était à 40 mille
patients on va dire nouveau par jour fin
de semaine on était à quarante et un
mille des bulles à ce matin on est à 52
il le professeur delfraissy du conseil
scientifique annonce pour amender
chiffre à 100 milles alors c'est quelque
part au milieu mais chose de sûr c'est
que on retrouve des niveaux beaucoup
plus inquiétant même que la première
vague
je vous rappelle qu'en première vague on
avait à peu près 2000 61 lits de coded
sur l'ensemble la région auvergne
rhône-alpes et avec trois régions en
france
les hôtes france ile de france et le
grand test est là avec pratiquement 60%
de la population sur notre région
auvergne rhône-alpes
on est déjà à 3000 lits c'est à dire
mais les deux plus qu'au plus fort de la
crise vers le 6 avril et cerise sur le
gâteau à l'asie cerise sur le gâteau à
l'asile ce qu'ils veulent et quand le
gâteau si vous voulez à l'époque avec
2000 lits on avait on avait la majorité
de nos lits de chirurgie disponibles
puisque on avait fait un arrêt brutal de
la chirurgie il y avait un conflit de la
population actuellement il ya des gens
ils sont encore opéré on essaye de vider
avec les services on va dire de médecine
de chirurgie de ce qu'être on va dire
reporter on vide les services de soins
de suite de réadaptation par exemple mon
établissement
on a fait sortir des gens par
anticipation qu'on va confier à la
médecine libérale avec des infirmiers
des pharmaciens des kinés de ville de
manière à pouvoir obtenir des lits avec
le de l'oxygène et absorber cette onde
de choc mais à mon avis avoir du mal à
absorber et nous couvre feu qui est mis
en place actuellement il n'est pas
suffisant selon vous même scénario lane
si vous voulez le couvre-feu à 21h vous
avez le temps dans le d'aller d'abord au
restaurant des fassis par table et vous
avez le temps d'organiser votre soirée
pyjama vous pouvez même et si plus
affinités en mariant avec le matelas
avait couché avec les copains on l'a vu
sur marie claude et ambre avec eux la
rentrée étudiante et universitaire ça a
été une vraie catastrophe
la moitié de l'école de lyon centrale de
lyon a été contaminé parce qu'ils
avaient fait un bizutage et une soirée
festive d'intronisation c'est normal
c'est c'est dans la culture des jeunes
le problème c'est que quand vous avez
les mêmes qui sont
sur les berges du rhône à on va dire ça
touche touche ça peut pas fonctionner il
est bien trop laxiste road interactions
sociales aujourd'hui notamment dans la
sphère privée
bien sûr vous avez tout à fait raison il
ya une interaction qui secret et la
problématique qu'on a elle est simple
c'est on doit la france est à genoux un
genou à terre avec cette première vague
on pensait avoir une reprise économique
en septembre et les ports vous entendez
le patron du medef qui vous explique si
on re confie de la france c'est la fin
on vient de se prendre un point de
dettes on va dire supplémentaires on a
10% de pib en moins les gens sont au
bout du rouleau les soignants sont
fatigués et vous mettez en prime le fait
qu' on va avoir un impact maintenant du
dur c'est à dire que les gens vont
commencer à recevoir leur lettre de
licenciement parce que les boîtes vont
fermer les unes après les autres
si vous rajoutez un gros film en
économie c'est l'ensemble du tissu
économique français qui va commencer à
se déliter
donc si vous voulez y arriver il n'y a
pas de miracle vous avez vous pousser
les gens à travailler pour maintenir un
lien on va dire avec le travail aux fins
du télétravail au maximum vous faites
une distribution de masques à toute la
population y compris aux jeunes même aux
enfants de manière à maintenir les
écoles ouvertes les universités ouvertes
avec des précautions vous allez faire
des rotations sur les cantines des
choses comme ça et que vous rentrez chez
vous à 19h couvre-feu donc ça a marché
en première la considère qu compatible
avec un équilibre entre les guinéens
rassembler la france meurt ça c'est
clair je dirais quand vous avez 50 de
mille patients nouveau par jour
ça veut dire que dans trois semaines
nous aurons à gérer nous médecins
pratiquement 260 décès de plus tous les
jours
rappelez-vous dans tous les villages de
france vous avez un monument aux morts
mais avec des noms qui s'égrènent de
façon effroyable un million cinq cent
mille soldats tués au front pour
défendre la patrie
très bien maintenant quand vous avez un
qui meurt à barque
c'est le drame on n'est pas prêts à
payer le prix humain et quand vous en
avez un qui meurt en métropole c'était
aussi un drap donc cette épidémie va
emporter on va dire on est actuellement
sur un train d'être en 4000 décès on va
rapidement attendre quarante mille et
plus vous savez on a éveillé la saison à
mulhouse on va adorer la saison bleus à
lyon malheureusement et et le fait de
laisser toutes les écoles ouvertes ya eu
un débat de savoir si c'était si ça
générait des foyers de contamination ou
non qu est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
à ce sujet là aujourd'hui il ya ya les
deux et deux éléments à prendre en
compte
le premier c'est qu'on sait pertinemment
qu laisse son porteur mais ils sont
porteurs sains et ils n'ont quasiment
pas de symptômes les adolescents c'est
pratiquement la même chose mais par
contre si vous fermez les écoles si vous
fermer des classes même primaire qu'est
ce que vont faire les parents ils vont
les garder les gosses dont vous allez
littéralement dézinguer l'économie
française
donc il faut laisser avec des moyens de
protection alors là il faut ouvrir les
spots de l'état ferment et faire en
sorte que vous puissiez avoir une à
maintien de sociétaux affectif dans
cette société qui en a besoin
outil bien aller à l'école imaginez les
gosses qui ont vécu le confinement le
ceux qui étaient au travail qu'ils ont
acquis on a essayé dans ces langues
étrangères ont fait du télétravail mais
ça va je pars forcément très bien donc
il ya déjà une belle chose ô combien une
perte de chance pour tous les patients
qu'on est obligé de repousser leur père
j y compris les pathologies cancéreuses
le pendant la période de confinement où
je rappelle que sur ma région on a
littéralement vu disparaître 300
presque 300 cancer du sein on aurait dû
les voir on les a pas vus puisqu'on n'a
pas pu faire l'examen on n'a pas
rattrapé ce nombre de cancers quand vous
êtes impatients et que vous avez un
cancer le réaliser vous avez une chance
quand vous êtes métastatique parce que
votre traitement a pris trois mois de
retard n'est pas pu voir le chirurgien
c'est plus du tout la même chose merci
beaucoup
pierre jeantet remaniant d'avoir répondu
à nos questions rappelle que vous êtes
médecin radiologue président de l'union
régionale des professionnels de santé
libéraux de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes